[Music]
before you go up on the floor i just
want to give you a few tips on how to
beat a good santa claus go right ahead
well here's a list of toys that we have
to push you know
things that we're overstocked on now
you'll find that a great many children
will be undecided as to what they want
for christmas when that happens you
immediately suggest one of these items
oh ho ho merry christmas everybody that
is my best impersonation of santa claus
and christmas has come to represent
different things to people over the
years and the movies here reflect that
in kind so if you're traditional and
you're feeling nostalgic you'll be
pleased to see where these movies fit on
our list of the best christmas movies
ranked by tomato meter and if this time
of year reminds you of sitting around
the tv eagerly awaiting those annual
specials look out for charlie brown
christmas and how the grinch stole
christmas we've also got christmas
movies in multiple genres like comedy
action drama and there's even a touch of
spooky and if christmas means traveling
somewhere you don't want to be stuck in
a building with people you don't like
have we got the ultimate movie for you
what did santa bring you honey
wondering how we put this christmas
movie list together i know it's keeping
you up at night so i am here to tell you
that every movie on this list is fresh
and plays around with the script of
christmas and the holidays as a central
theme then we sorted them all by our
ranked formula which factors in the
movie's release year and its number of
reviews to make the ultimate list of
holiday films that melted even the most
cynical critics hearts and now you're
ready to enter a wonderland of cinematic
history as we count down the best
christmas movies ever
[Music]
starting with number 10 tangerine
after hearing that her boyfriend cheated
on her while she was in jail a sex
worker and her best friend set out to
find him and teach him and his new lover
a lesson starring katana kiki rodriguez
maya taylor karen kerrigullian and
directed by sean baker critics say
tangerine shatters casting conventions
and its filmmaking techniques are up to
the minute but it's an old-fashioned
comedy at heart and a pretty wonderful
one at that point
that is a cute little
stick it is
i'm doing drugs can you please tell her
i i don't do drugs no please no no no no
he don't do my drugs
are you crazy
prostitution
how you say this russian
oh
spots the beautiful elegant carol
perusing the doll displays in a 1950s
manhattan department store the two women
develop a fast bond that becomes a love
with complicated consequences starring
kate blanchette rooney mara sarah
paulson and directed by todd haynes
critics say shaped by todd haynes's deft
direction and powered by a strong cast
led by cate blanchett and rooney mara
carol lives up to its groundbreaking
source material
and your muse
oh
thank you thank you
i'm starved
bon appetit
what do you do on sundays
nothing in particular what do you do
oh
nothing lately
i mean if you'd like to come visit me
sometime
you're welcome to
at least there's some pretty country
around where i live
would you like to come visit me this
sunday
yes
whose strange girl you are
why
long enough space
number eight meet me in st louis
meet me in st louis is a classic mgm
romantic musical comedy that focuses on
four sisters on the cusp of the 1904 st
louis world's fair now the film
spotlights the sisters is education in
the ways of the world which includes but
isn't limited to learning about life and
love courtesy of the prototypical boy
next door in the end love accompanied by
song and dance and period costumes all
in glorious technicolor conquers all
starring judy garland margaret o'brien
leon ames and directed by vincent
minelli critics say a disarmingly sweet
musical led by outstanding performances
from judy garland and margaret o'brien
meet me in st louis offers a holiday
treat for all ages katie this is
delicious
well
i guess this hasn't been exactly a red
letter day for any of us
now suppose we all relax and enjoy a
nice leisurely meal
katie i'm sorry i couldn't eat an hour
early don't blame me if the corn beef's
an hour tougher
you finished already tutti that's the
way i like to see you eat
you'll be a big girl if
either i've lost some super i found a
spoon
oh katie
lonnie did you have a nice day at the
office oh no you didn't did you
okay rose did you hear that they're
having a fashion provision at the
world's fair isn't that exciting we have
to wait
dessert what happened to dinner i didn't
think anybody could eat meat on a hot
day like this well i'm not hot i just
had a nice cool bath which nobody can
take away from me and i have every
intention of eating an enormous dinner
and
i think katie's getting a little old her
mental process is baffled me
number seven little women in the years
after the civil war joe march lives in
new york and makes her living as a
writer while her sister amy studies
painting in paris amy has a chance
encounter with theodore a childhood
crush who proposed to joe but was
ultimately rejected their oldest sibling
meg is married to a schoolteacher while
shy's sister beth develops a devastating
illness that brings the family back
together starring cersei ronan emma
watson florence pugh and directed by
greta gerwig critics say with a stellar
cast and a smart sensitive retelling of
its classic source material greta
gerwig's little women prove some stories
truly are
[Music]
the timeless the most important part
when you're wasting decorations and
they're not dangling the sides aren't
the most important fit
here's another christmas gift for the
marsh family
my little women
[Music]
oh you've grown
open
merry christmas my dear
merry christmas to each of you
merry christmas
[Music]
thank god
thank god you're home
thank god for you
now i can be angry with you in person
[Music]
number six the nightmare before
christmas
the film follows the misadventures of
jack skellington halloweentown's beloved
pumpkin king who has become bored with
the same annual routine of frightening
people in the real world now when jack
accidentally stumbles on christmas town
all bright colors and warm spirits he
gets a new lease on life he plots to
bring christmas under his control by
kidnapping santi claus and taking over
the role but jack soon discovers that
even the best laid plans of mice and
skeleton men can go seriously awry
starring chris sarandon catherine o'hara
ken page and directed by henry selick
critics say the nightmare before
christmas is a stunningly original and
visually delightful work of stop motion
animation
[Music]
[Music]
my
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
number five how the grinch stole
christmas
this made for tv christmas special is a
classic based on a dr seuss book it is
about a christmas-hating grinch who
wants to make everyone as miserable on
christmas as he is the poor
small-hearted scrooge learns the true
meaning of christmas through the loving
who's in whoville starring boris karloff
june forrey thurl ravenscroft and
directed by chuck jones critics say how
the grinch stole christmas brings an
impressive array of talent to bear on an
adaptation that honors a classic holiday
story and has rightfully become a
yuletide tradition of its
slugged to the own
he took the who's feast
he took the whole pudding he took the
roast beast he cleaned out the icebox as
quick as a flash why that grinch even
took the last can of who hash
then he stuffed all the food up the
chimney with glee i'll grin the grinch
i will stuff up the tree
[Music]
as the grinch took the tree as he
started to sharpie he heard a small
sound like the cool of a dove he turned
around fast and he saw a small who
little cindy lou who who was no more
than two
she stared at the grinch and said
sandy claus why
why are you taking our christmas tree
why
but you know
that old grinch was so smart and so
slick he thought up a lie and he thought
he looked quick
number four the shop around the corner
alfred krolick and clara novak are
employees at matuchek and company a
general store in budapest now clara and
alfred are constantly at odds with each
other butting heads and disagreeing on
almost everything both are enamored of
their respective pen pals who serve as
welcome distractions in their lives
little do they know they are each the
others pen pal and despite outward
differences have unwittingly fallen in
love through their letters starring
margaret sullivan james stewart frank
morgan and directed by ernst lubich
critics say definitely directed by ernst
lubich from a smart funny script by
samson raphaelsen the shop around the
corner is a romantic comedy in the
finest sense of the
term good morning mr pervice good
morning oh the first one huh it's none
of your business and let me tell you it
doesn't hurt to be too early what for
and why who sees you me and who sees me
you
why does it get us can we give each
other a raise
no
what are you doing with that bicycle
you're not supposed to take that home
better not let mr matashek see it why
don't you tell him it's all right with
me do you know where i was last night
while you were home soaking your feet in
hot water running my legs off for mrs
matacek pepe go to the dressmaker and
when i come back oh pepe will you please
pick up a package at the drugstore good
morning
good morning miss catcher good morning
how's your little boy much better thanks
we call dr hagerdush oh he's a very
expensive doctor well what can you do
i figured i'd cut down on my cigars for
a few weeks good morning good morning
good morning good morning oh that's a
new swivel fox it's stunning thank you
it must have been pretty expensive oh it
was
i hesitated a long time before i bought
it i said no i can't afford it and still
i couldn't take my eyes off it and then
i said no i have no right then he said
i'll go on and take it oh trying to be
clever
all right morning mister
probably happy you go over the drugstore
and get me a bicarbonate soda what's a
medicare don't you feel about it no it's
all right
number three holiday inn
in this irving berlin musical jim and
lila are members of a performing trio
who plan to quit and run a country hotel
when lila says that she's fallen in love
with the dancer in the act ted jim
leaves town with a broken heart after
turning the end into a holidays only
live entertainment venue jim winds up
booking and falling for linda but when
ted shows up at the place after being
dumped by lila he too sets his sights on
beautiful linda starring bing crosby
fred astaire marjorie reynolds and
directed by mark sandrich critics say
with the combined might of bing crosby
fred astaire and irving berlin working
in its favor holiday inn is a seasonal
classic not least because it introduced
white christmas to the world
hello boys
i paid up cards here tonight
where's the surprise
uh-huh right here
little home cooking i whipped in
beautiful
be careful it's my heart
no you're kidding either
i wrote this just for you honey
number two miracle on 34th street in
this christmas classic an old man going
by the name of kris kringle fills in for
an intoxicated santa in macy's annual
thanksgiving day parade now kringle
proves to be such a hit that he is soon
appearing regularly at the chain's main
store in midtown manhattan now when
kringle surprises customers and
employees alike by claiming that he
really is santa claus it leads to a
court case to determine his mental
health and more importantly his
authenticity starring maureen o'hara
john payne edmond gwen and directed by
george ceon critics say irrefutable
proof that gentle sentimentalism can be
the chief ingredient in a wonderful film
miracle on 34th street delivers a warm
holiday message without resorting to
treacle what i'm trying to explain to
you is come in
he said you wanted to see me mrs baldwin
come right in hello there good to see
you again it's nice to see you you're
awfully lucky mrs walker lovely little
girl you have here thank you and susan's
the reason i asked you to drop down
she's a little confused and i thought
maybe you could help to straighten her
out i'd be glad to would you please tell
her that you're not really santa claus
that there actually is no such person
well i'm sorry to disagree with you mrs
walker but not only this is such a
person but here i am to prove it no no
no you misunderstand i want you to tell
her the truth uh what's your name chris
crinkle i'll bet you're in the first
grade second
i mean your real name that is my real
name second grade it's a progressive
school oh it's a progressive school
may i have this gentleman's employment
card please yes mrs walker this dress is
very cute where did you get such a
lovely outfit here at macy's we get 10
percent off
please don't feel that you have to keep
pretending for susan's benefit she's a
very intelligent child and always wants
to know the absolute truth good because
i always tell the absolute truth now
about your school what's the name of
your teacher mrs haley mrs haley here it
is mrs walker thank you
what else do you do besides read and
play games
and before we reveal number one here are
some honorable mentions
a charlie brown christmas
christmas time is here happiness and
cheer and for peanuts fans everywhere it
just wouldn't be christmas without this
classic holiday delight christmas lights
may be twinkling red and green but
charlie brown has the yuletide blues to
get in the holiday spirit he takes
lucy's advice and directs the christmas
play and what's a christmas play without
a christmas tree but everyone makes fun
of the short spindly never green charlie
brown brings back until the real meaning
of christmas works its magic once again
starring peter robbins christopher shay
tracy stratford and directed by bill
melendez and phil roman gregory weinkoff
from new times says it's truly wonderful
even followers of zoroaster can dig it
the choreography is particularly spiffy
snoopy you'll have to be all the animals
in our play can you be a sheep
how about a cow
how about a penguin
yes he's even a good penguin
no no no
listen all of you you've got to take
direction you've got to have discipline
you've got to have respect for your
director
i ought to slug you
ugh i've been kissed by a dog i have dog
germs get hot water get some
disinfectant get some iodine
all right all right script girl continue
with the scripts
linus you've got to get rid of that
stupid blanket and here memorize these
lines i can't memorize these lines this
is
it and be ready to recite when your cue
comes i can't memorize something like
this so quickly why should i be put
through such agony
give me one good reason why i should
memorize this
i'll give you five good reasons one two
three four five those are good reasons
christmas is not only getting too
commercial it's getting too dangerous
die hard
new york city policeman john mclean is
visiting his estranged wife and two
daughters on christmas eve he joins her
at a holiday party in the headquarters
of the japanese-owned business that she
works for but the festivities are
interrupted by a group of terrorists who
take over the exclusive high-rise and
everyone in it very soon mclean realizes
that there's no one to save the hostages
but him starring bruce willis alan
rickman bonnie bedelia and directed by
john mctiernan critics say it's many
imitators and sequels have never come
close to matching the top thrills of the
definitive holiday action classic
mr mystery guest
are you still there
yeah i'm still here unless you want to
open a front door for me
no i'm afraid not
but you have me at a loss
you know my name but who are you
just another american who saw too many
movies as a child
another orphan of a bankrupt culture who
thinks he's john wayne
rambo
marshall dylan
i was always kind of partial to roy
rogers actually
i really like those sequin shirts
do you really think you have a chance
against us mr cowboy
mother
arthur christmas
everyone knows that each christmas santa
claus delivers presents to every last
child on earth what everyone doesn't
know is that santa accomplishes the beat
with a very high-tech operation beneath
the north pole but when the unthinkable
happens and santa misses one child out
of hundreds of millions someone has to
save the day it's up to arthur santa's
youngest son to deliver a present to the
forgotten tyke before christmas morning
dawns starring james mcavoy hugh laurie
bill nye and directed by sarah smith
critics say aardman animations broadens
their humor a bit for arthur christmas a
clever and earnest holiday film with
surprisingly emotional strength reno
your ho-ho is equipped with
state-of-the-art emf sensor technology
hacked directly from the military's
missile program i want you to locate the
batteries and perform a level three gift
wrap incision
go in through the robin
i did my 70 missions without any of this
malarkey
didn't we laugh
twist eyes clearly can i watch with you
grand santa shut that door hell's
berries is the normal pole is the kid
still asleep he mustn't see santa dad
would rather die than spoil it for it
what if you do wake the odd nipper a
whack on the head with a sock for a sand
and a dab of whiskey on the lips i don't
remember in the morning
screwdriver else yes
what happened to going down the chimney
basket here you are grand center i've
made you a nice minced pie i can't eat
that it gets in mid teeth oh dear no
i've just got to visit the elf hospital
look over a treaty with greenland and
make the gravy then we'll finally have
the whole family home for christmas and
finally number one it's a wonderful life
after george bailey wishes he had never
been born an angel is sent to earth to
make george's wishes come true george
starts to realize how many lives he has
changed and impacted and how they would
be different if he was never there
starring james stewart donna reed lionel
barrymore and directed by frank kappa
critics say the holiday classic to
define all holiday classics it's a
wonderful life is one of a handful of
films worth an annual viewing mary i
know what i'm gonna do tomorrow and the
next day and next year and a year after
that i'm shaking the dust of this crummy
little town off my feet and i'm gonna
see the world
italy greece the parthenon the coliseum
then i'm coming back here and go to
college and see what they know and then
i'm gonna build things i'm gonna build
airfields i'm gonna build skyscrapers a
hundred stories high i'm gonna build
bridges a mile long
what are you gonna throw a rock
hey that's pretty good
what'd you wish mary
buffalo girls can't you come out today
can't you come on tonight
tonight
can't you come out tonight
dance by the light of the moon
what'd you wish when you threw that
wrong
oh no come on tell me if i told you it
might not come true what is it you want
barry
what do you what you you want the moon
just say the word and i'll throw a lasso
around and pull it down
hey that's a pretty good idea
i'll give you the moon mary i'll take it
and friends that about does it for us be
sure to stay tuned to the rotten
tomatoes channel for more of the
entertainment content that you love and
for even more new scores and
recommendations on the latest tv shows
and movies head on over to
rottentomatoes.com until next time i'm
your host naz perez and we'll see you
back here for more top 10s on the rotten
tomatoes countdown
[Music]
you